what oscar-winning actor made a rare
cameo on viva la bam which of the show's
stars has been behind bars
and is it all really unscripted if you
thought you knew everything about bam
margera's popular mtv prank series think
again
the officially credited creators of
jackass are johnny knoxville jeff
tremaine and spike jones and all three
have remained the heads of the franchise
throughout its existence when jackass
stars chris pontius and steve oh decided
to put together their own spin-off show
they teamed up with tremaine to
co-create and co-produce wild boys it
was clear that pontius and stevo wanted
some familiar names to be on board to
give wild boys that trademark jackass
feel however when bam margera decided to
lead his own show he went in the
opposite direction and specifically
sought out fresh blood to help him bring
viva la bam to life margera co-created
viva la bam with troy miller by then
already a veteran producer and director
best known at the time as one of the
executive producers of hbo's acclaimed
alt comedy sketch series mr show with
bob and david miller not only brought
along an extra level of polish not seen
in the intentionally scrappy jackass
series but more importantly proved that
margera could lead a successful tv
series without having to rely on the
people that put jackass on the air
a show like viva la bam involves filming
a ton of footage that never gets used as
things are edited down in order to fit
into 30 minute tv episodes however it's
not often that an entire episode's worth
of footage is scrapped entirely if for
no other reason then doing so means
throwing away whatever money was spent
on getting that footage but that is
exactly what happened when the viva la
bam crew traveled to iceland in order to
force ryan dunn to back up some bragging
according to bam margera dunn was at a
bar claiming that he would have gone
over a waterfall in a barrel during a
previous trip to iceland but didn't
because it was too cold bam decided to
call him out flying dunn and some others
to iceland the next day to challenge
dunn to do the trick in what was then a
warmer season in the country the very
next day we're going to iceland
sure enough dunn did it and it was
caught on tape along with a bunch of
other footage that could have comprised
an entire iceland-based episode however
margera said mtv felt the stunt was too
easy to replicate and feared that too
many viewers would try it so the network
next to the episode entirely not only
never airing it but also not including
it on any of the official dvd releases
of viva la bam thus cementing its status
as the show's infamous lost episode
by the time viva la bam started airing
bam margera was frustrated with how much
credit johnny knoxville had received as
a creator and also de facto lead of
jackass because as margera argued it was
he and his friends doing skateboard and
shopping cart based stunt videos that
truly set the stage for what the show
would become it's a sentiment he once
again echoed after his jackass forever
exit saying in a statement i created
this franchise before any of these guys
ever got involved the two would mend
fences in time to film jackass number
two together and seemingly remained
friends throughout jackass 3d but their
friendship has since been severed yet
again for reasons both creative and
personal as proof of how margera was
feeling about knoxville in those days
look no further than the fact that
knoxville only appeared once throughout
the 40-episode run of viva la bam which
suggested that the two weren't exactly
best buds at the time further evidence
came in the form of knoxville not making
any appearance whatsoever in marjera and
ryan dunn's 2003 movie haggard despite
it featuring appearances by most of the
jackass crew as well as famous friends
like tony hawk
one might assume that none of the shows
that spun off from jackass were quite as
successful as the flagship series
however it's easy to forget that jackass
didn't actually last all that long as a
tv show the series meager three seasons
didn't even stretch across a full two
years and when all was said and done
only 25 episodes were produced it might
seem like it lasted much longer than it
did since mtv re-ran those three seasons
for years
especially when it was time to promote a
new movie but the original run of
jackass was a short one indeed with that
in mind it wouldn't have been all that
hard for viva la bam to outlast jackass
but it's still impressive that it did
the episode count exceeded jackass by 15
ending its run at 40 episodes stretched
across five seasons it's not hard to
imagine that bam margera was proud to
have his solo venture outlast jackass
especially given his feelings about
jackass and its creative leadership at
the time if margera was feeling
competitive with the other jackass
spin-off wild boys he also beat that
series as it only made it to 32 episodes
when all is said and done viva la bam
remains the longest running show
starring or featuring any members of the
jackass crew
the episode of viva la bam that featured
johnny knoxville also had another
surprising appearance oscar-winning
actor sean penn penn came along with his
then 11 year old son hopper a budding
skateboarder who was the more likely
reason the father-son duo appeared on
the show as he was probably the viva la
bam fan though sean certainly seemed to
be enjoying himself as well but it was
hopper who got his hands dirty by
pouring paint on johnny knoxville's car
as part of a prank war between knoxville
and marjera in the episode hopper is now
a full-fledged actor in his own right
with numerous credits to his name as it
stands viva la bim is his earliest
credit which means the show is
technically his screen debut hopper's
acting career post viva la bam might
have started sooner but some personal
struggles including his parents divorce
and a near-fatal skateboarding accident
in his teens put such ambitions on hold
for a few years but he did get back on
the board and has since become a very
talented skateboarder
by all accounts viva la bam was truly an
unscripted show sure a lot of the pranks
involved a fair amount of planning and
setup but that doesn't mean that the
victims knew what was coming or that
their reactions weren't genuine some of
the best reactions came from bam
margera's mom april who always made the
best faces and gave the best screams
when she was on the receiving end of a
prank but she also spilled the tea a bit
about how it was often pretty easy to
know when a stunt was coming margera has
confirmed that april in particular could
usually figure out that he was cooking
something up when he'd just be hanging
around at her house with an mtv crew so
when she'd come home or wake up and
margera would be standing in her kitchen
surrounded by cameras and production
people she knew she was in for something
but at least she was a good enough sport
to not ask a million questions and just
go with the flow
at this point there's little arguing
that johnny knoxville is the biggest
solo success story of any of the jackass
crew not only did he front his own
spin-off movie jackass presents bad
grandpa but he has appeared in multiple
major hollywood productions such as the
dukes of hazzard and the 2014 teenage
mutant ninja turtles movie but when viva
la bam was on the air it seemed as
though that distinction was going to
belong to bam margera not only had
margera co-created a popular tv series
but during that time his skateboard line
was doing extremely well he launched his
own serious satellite radio channel
started a music label appeared in
multiple video games and co-wrote and
directed a movie unfortunately none of
his business or media projects proved to
have much staying power and worst of all
addiction really started to become an
issue for both his professional and
personal life margiera still has
multiple projects going at any given
time but he's yet to reach the heights
he was poised to scale in the mid-2000s
viva la bam was a successful show by
most measurements it was so successful
in fact that it was a no-brainer for mtv
to give him a follow-up show to pick up
where viva la bam left off which ended
up being bam's unholy union a little
more grounded than the usual bam based
fare bam's unholy union followed margera
as he planned his wedding with
then-fiance missy rothstein with the
finale of the first season depicting the
wedding in question a second season
wasn't discussion but didn't end up
happening on an episode of his radio
show radio bam margera claimed mtv
wanted him and his wife to fake a
pregnancy for the second season which
they were unwilling to do margera has
also stated that rothstein wasn't a fan
of being on television it would be three
years before margera would attempt
another show in 2010 he teamed up with
spike tv for bam's world domination
which saw margero ryan dunn and tim
o'connor attempt a vicious obstacle
course there's some mixed messaging as
to whether it was originally intended to
be a pilot for a full series or just a
one-off special but a one-off special is
all it would ever be four more years
would pass before marjera would try tv
again this time with bam's badass game
show on tbs which didn't last beyond its
initial six episode order kayla
i'm sorry but you have to go home
guess what you won what nothing
bam margera's first love and what put
him on the path to jackass and the
mainstream celebrity status is
skateboarding he was even a professional
skateboarder for a time with a
skateboard line that rivaled tony hawks
in sales at its peak jackass had a
loosey-goosey enough schedule that it
didn't interfere with margera's
skateboarding too much but being the
lead star and one of the main people
behind a show like viva la bam is a
totally different story suddenly margero
was struggling to find the time to skate
even for fun and he wasn't happy about
it his solution to make skateboarding a
huge part of viva la bam and have some
of the stunts involve skating and
building impromptu skate parks in this
way he could manage to star in and run
his own show but still have an excuse to
get plenty of board time in since it was
woven into the fabric of viva la bam
because jackass was born from
skateboarding based big brother magazine
and its fans and staff skating has
always been in the dna of the jackass
universe but never was it more prominent
than it was in viva la bam
vincent don vito margera was one of the
big breakout stars of viva la bam the
real-life uncle of van margera and
brother of phil margera vito had made
appearances in jackass but it wasn't
until viva la bam that he was made a
prominent figure and truly became a
minor celebrity in his own right i want
what i had i want to be made whole again
give me what the hell i had and leave me
to hell known for his exaggerated
reaction to pranks as well as his speech
being almost impossible to understand
most of the time veto was a fixture of
the show and one of the biggest sources
of comic relief throughout its entire
run
we got pies down there
[Music]
however in 2006 vito was arrested for
allegedly having inappropriate physical
contact with two 12-year-old girls he
was found guilty on two counts of sexual
assault and sentenced to ten years of
probation during which time the court
forbade him from portraying the persona
of don vito publicly in any way after
the fallout of his arrest and probation
scenes filmed featuring him for jackass
number two were removed and despite
appearing briefly in one scene of bam's
unholy union he was otherwise absent
from the series don vito would remain
effectively removed from public life for
his remaining years passing away in 2015
before his probation would have ended
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mtv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]